with the dreamville thing who
who from dreamville was it eve was it
like who was it that originally
like tapped in with you to become a part
of the uh the revenge of the dreamer
sessions
[ __ ] cold it was cold yeah that was the
original thing i met cole
uh at the nice guy
leaving uh drake's new years thing and
he was like yo
take my number down before you leave and
i texted him
immediately and he texts me back right
everyone says that and then
it was so crazy to me i was like i tell
that story every time because nobody's
ever done that
right nobody especially even people who
i'm closer friends with now like bryson
my man bryson
it took him a minute to text me back and
i'm hella cool
i'm closer to bryson i am cold but
that just when he texted me back like
that i was like damn
i [ __ ] with that a hell of [ __ ] with
that
and the homie ryan at the time who i was
[ __ ] around with from a previous
a label situation shout out fly rye was
also in and around
the dreamville camp so we had cole
bringing me up right like oh no
i know that [ __ ] no come on and then
it just kind of fell into place it
worked out beautifully you got a grammy
nomination
right [ __ ] that's forever forever
forever forever ever yeah